ونحييكم من جديد الى هذه التغطيه المستمره
مشاهدينا ضد تطورات في السودان ما يحدث في
السودان لن يبقى داخل حدوده فقط سباعيه
افريقيه قد تتاثر بتفاقم النزاع اكثر
فخروج دوي الانفجارات واقطل الشوارع عن
مساحه المليون وثمانمائه
ليس مستبعدا جوله اولى من حرب اهليه قد
تمتد الى 70 يتشارك السودان حدودا ملتهبه
معهاد الى عاملين مدى استمراريه النزاع
والعمل الثاني نتيجه هذا النزاع ساعه
اخباريه جديده من تغطيه للاحداث في
السودان نحييكم
[موسيقى]
حقائب موظبه وصرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثالث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل لانه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيش
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيين على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرق الجهود المشتركه للتوصل
لاتفاق بشان صد النهضه التهديد المائي ليس
فقط ما تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها
الكهرومائيه فالمناوشات على الحدود غير
منقطعه اصلا وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده
التوتر بمنطقه الفشجه الخصبه الحدوديه
المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينابع من مخاوف امتداد
الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين ومعظمهم
من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع ميليشيات
الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات احمدتي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور نشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه الفا من مواطنيها قد يضطرون
لحزم امتعتهم من جديد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى بعض
العواجر التي ادت عن الخارجيه الاثيوبيه
التي تؤكد ان صحه للتقارير التي تتحدث عن
تدخل اثيوبيا في السودان الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه كذلك تقول نسعى لتهدئه الاوضاع
في السودان بعيدا عن التقارير الوهميه كما
اسمتها وان ما يحدث في السودان هو شان
داخلي هو مستعد للوساطه اذا طلب من ذلك
الخارجيه الاثيوبيه كذلك تقول انها تراقب
عن كثب وضع الجاليه الاثيوبيه الكبيره في
السودان مجموعه من العواجل التي سنبقى في
متابعتها عن الخارجيه الاثيوبيه والاكيد
باننا سنناقشها كذلك في سياق هذه النشره
خاصه وان البعض بدا يتحدث عن تاثير هذه
الحرب الدائره وهذه الازمه الدائره في
داخل السوداني عن
التاثير هذه الحرب على
المجاوره سنبقى في متابعه هذه التطورات مع
ضيفنا من القاهره الصحفي الارتري محمد ابو
بكر المختص في شؤون الافريقيه سيد محمود
اهلا بك معنا سيد محمود الى اي مدام مخاوف
البعض من ان ينسحب الوضع في السودان على
الحدود وبالتالي ان يؤثر على دول الجوار
الى اي مداف هذه القراءه دقيقه
مساء الخير في الواقع التدخلات الموجوده
بين اثيوبيا والسودان وكذلك بين دول
الجوار القرن الافريقي عموما هناك تداخل
كبير جدا سكاني وكذلك
على المستوى الاجتماعي والسياسي والثقافي
هناك تدخلات كبيره كما ان هناك نزوح ونزوح
مضاد بين كل الاطراف
المتواجده في هذه المنطقه سواء في اثيوبيا
في السودان وبالتالي الانعكاس متوقع باي
شكل من الاشكال كذلك كما تعلمون ان حرب
الاخيره في اثيوبيا في الشمال اثيوبيا كان
لها انعكاس مباشر ايضا على السودان حيث
واجه الطرفان تواجه الطرفان
والسوداني على الحدود في مناطق محدده
متنازع عليها بين الطرفين وهناك حقوق او
ادعاء او ادعاء مناقب بينهما حول ملكيه كل
طرف لهذه الحدود وبالتالي
انا ايضا لاستعال الحرب في السودان قد
ينعكس على المناطق الحدوديه المحاديه
ونحن نتحدث عن مخاوف كذلك ان يعيد تاريخ
نفسه وان تكون هناك حركات او تحركات
لمجموعات مسلحه عبر الحدود بين اثيوبيا
واريتريا هل هذا وارد
بين اثيوبيا بينما السودان عفوا نعم بين
السودان واثيوبيا وارد جدا خاصه كما
تعلمين هناك اصلا مشكله سواء كانت في
تنازع على مناطق حدوديه في منطقه
وكذلك هناك تواجد لمسلحين من بني شنقول
الذين هم في الاساس تاريخيا هم سودانيين
ولكن تابعون اقليميا اول جغرافيا لاثيوبيا
ولديهم حركات مسلحه يقال او يتهم السودان
بتمويلها كذلك حركه تحرير
لديها علاقات
وارتباطات بالسودان وهناك اتهامات اثيوبيه
للسودان رسميا
بتسليح او بدعم هذه الحركه فبالتالي هناك
بالتاكيد سيكون لهذه الحرب السودانيه
الداخليه امتداد اقليمي
وبالذات على المستوى الاثيوبي كما تلاحظين
ايضا ان اثيوبيا في المره الماضيه عندما
بدات ثوره ديسمبر في السودان كانت اثيوبيا
هي الوسيط الرئيسي لانهاء الازمه بين
الثوار بين
المجلس العسكري الذي كان
حاكما وقتها بعد سقوط نظام البشير ولكن
تبدو اثيوبيا الان اقل حماسا في قياده اي
مبادره حتى الان وكما ذكرتي في بيان وزاره
الخارجيه حدد ما اذا رغبت السودان لان
هناك مياه كثيره جارت تحت الجسور بعد
بدايه حرب هي تقول ان طلب من ذلك يمكن ان
ادخل في اطار الوساطه ولكن سيد محمود
هل اتخذت السلطات سلطات الدول المجاوره
اعلم بان حضرتك متواجد في القاهره ولكن
الاكيد بانك تتابع كذلك ما يصدر من بيانات
رسميه سواء عن اريتريا او اثيوبيا هل
تعتقد بان السلطات اتخذت
اجراءات مناسبه
قادره ان تحد من توسع هذه التطورات
هناك نوع من التحفز عن اعلان مواقف في هذه
المنطقه خاصه في اثيوبيا وفي اريتريا عدا
تلك الاعلانات الدبلوماسيه والمطالبه
بايقاف هذه الحرب والى ما الى ذلك ولكن لم
يتم هناك اعلان مباشر عن مواقف واضحه لكن
التحسبات بالتاكيد موجوده لان هناك حدود
مشتركه مشتعله على الدوام سواء كان في
الحدود الارثويه الاثيوبيه او الحدود
الاثيوبيه السودانيه او الحدود المشتركه
في
مثلث بين ثلاث دول في مناطق هم حجر مثلا
وكذلك هذه المناطق معروف معروفه بتواجد
المسلحين فيها سواء من هنا او هنا
وبالتالي هناك تحسبات كبيره جدا
لامكانيه ان تؤثر الحرب السودانيه على
منطقه القرن الافريقي ككل خاصه في ما
يتعلق بالنزوح الان هناك نزوح كبير جدا
للسودانيين
من مناطق مختلفه اذا استمرت
ريا واث نحن في الجهه المقابله الامم
المتحده تحدثت عن عمليه نزوح في اتجاه
تشاد
ولكن هل هناك نزوح كذلك يمكن ان نتحدث عنه
حتى الان لا اعتقد لان المناطق الحدوديه
لم تستحدث المناطق المستهدفه الان على
خلاف الحروب السابقه هي العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وبعض المدن الاخرى وبالتالي حتى
الان لم تصل الحرب او امتدادات الحرب الى
الحدود ولكن هناك نزوح سودانيه
ولكن السيد محمود جغرافيا الخرطوم قد تبدو
اقرب لكسلا للقضارف كذلك وبالتالي اقرب
لاريتريا لماذا يختار لماذا يختار البعض
ان يلجا الى الجهه المقابله الى تشاد وقد
تكون ابعد من حدود اثيوبيا
في اعتقاد هذا له علاقه بارتباطات
[موسيقى]
عرقيه وارتباطات ثقافيه واجتماعيه ايضا
لانه كما تعلمين ان
التدخل السريع والدعم السريع والدعم
السريع التي يقودها
حميتي هي بالاساس مرتبطه بمنطقه دارفور
المتاخمه للحدود التشاديه وهناك تدخل
سكاني كبير جدا وتداخل قبلي كبير جدا بعض
النازحين يخشون من رده فعل او من ردود فعل
وثارات او انتقام مما حدث الان بين
الفريقين المسلحين اعتقاد هذا احد الاسباب
تعلم حضرتك بانها ليست المره الاولى
السودان لها تاريخ في الازمات وفي الحروب
الاهليه وكذلك حتى في الصراعات الداخليه
عاده كيف تتعامل دول مثل اريتريا واثيوبيا
مع مثل هكذا ازمات
في اعتقادي في السابق كان لها ادوار كبيره
جدا ومعلنه
كان لها دورا معروفا ومشهودي منذ عام 1994
او 95 حيث ندمت مؤتمر القضايا الموثيريه
وجماعه المعارضه السودانيه حيث لم تكن
الحكومه الارثريه او النظام الاريثري
والنظام السوداني على وفاق ولذلك تم
استخدام كافه الحركات
والقوى السياسيه السودانيه التي المعارضه
وتم تاسيس تحالف كبير للمعارضه السودانيه
في اسمره سمي بمؤتمر القضايا المصدريه ثم
بعد ذلك ساهمت بعد تحسن علاقاتها مع
الخرطوم في عقد اتفاقيه الشرق الشرق
السودان وتم حللت بعض المشاكل العالقه
التي كانت بين الشرق السودان وبين المركز
اثيوبيا كما تعلمين هي التي هي الوسيطه
الرئيسيه التي انهت الازمه بعد قيام
ولذلك لكلا البلدين
تاثيرا واضحا في الداخل السوداني وكلا
البلدان لديهما علاقات واسعه مع القوى
السياسيه السودانيه سواء كانت على هذا
الطرف او ذاك وكانت قوه مسلحه سواء كانت
الجيش النظامي او او القوات
الدعم السريع حميدتي الان نعم
فكلا البلدان يتمتعان بعلاقات جيده مع كل
الاطراف ولكن تعقيدات الشان السوداني
حاليا وقيام الحرب بهذا الشكل الكبير ربما
منعهما من ابداء مبادره السيد محمود نقطه
ايجابيه ان تتحدث عن علاقه ايجابيه بين
هذه الاطراف واثيوبيا يعني تقول حضرتك بان
قوات القوات المسلحه وكذلك الدعم السريع
كلاهما له علاقات يعني حسنه جيده مع
اثيوبيا ولكن تتحدث كذلك عن تعقيدات
اضافيه مثل ماذا
التعقيدات الاساسيه تمثلت اولا بعض قيام
حرب كما ذكرت ربما يشعر الاثيوبيون ان
السودان استغل انشغال الجيش النظامي في
حرب الشمال وبالتالي حاول استعاده الاراضي
المتنازله عليها وبالفعل نجح السوداني في
استعاده جزء من الاراضي التي يدعي انها
تابعه له وبالتالي الاثيوبيون هذا
بيعتقدون بان هناك
ردود
الفعل السوداني على اتفاقيه السلام وما
ساهمت باثيوبيا في انهاء الازمه لم يكن
بذلك الشكل الذي توقعوه او يشعرون بخيبه
امل او استغلال لوضع الداخلي الاثيوبي
لاستعاده اراضي متنازع عليها وبالتالي ليس
هناك حماسا كبيرا من الجهه الرسميه للتوسط
للازمه السودانيه الحاليه بالاضافه الى
ذلك تعقيدات ملف سد النهضه الذي تعقد
في الفتره الاخيره بعد ان مضت اثيوبيا
باتجاه الثاني ثم الثالث
ودون العوده الى دولتي المصاب وهما مصروف
نسويا في هذا الملف وبالتالي هناك جوانب
ايجابيه صحيح وفي نفس الوقت هناك تحفظات
كبيره من الطرف الاثيوبي وكذلك من الطرف
اما اسباب الطرف الارتفاع اعتقادي بانه مع
بدايه الازمه بين القوه المعارضه وخاصه
قوه سودانيه المدنيه والمجلس العسكري او
المجلس الاعتيادي تقدمت بشكل رسمي
بمبادره او
حميده للتوسط بين كل هذه الاثار لما تتمتع
به من علاقات مع كافه هذه السياسيه لكن
تلك المبادره لم تقبل من قبل
المجلس السيادي وتحديدا من قبل اعتقادي
جنرال البرهان وبالتالي
غير مستعده ايضا بطرح مبادره اخرى ترفض او
لن تقبل ليست متحمسه طيب
سنبقى في متابعه كل هذه التطورات او تشكرك
جزيل الشكر في الواقع على كل ما تفضلت به
من معلومات وتحليل كذلك الصحفي الاريتري
محمود ابو بكر المختص في الشؤون الافريقيه
شكرا جزيلا لك ونتابع دائما مع ضيفنا من
جوبان ابراهيم
حذيفه محي الدين البلول اهلا بك معنا سيد
حذيفه سيد حذيفه منذ ايام قليله من الان
اصدرتم بيان تحدثتم فيه ووصفتم في هذا
الصراع قلتم بان المشكله
اساسا سياسيه بحثه وحلها لا يمكن ان يكون
الا سياسي طيب لماذا تعتقد حضرتك بان
وحضرتك لما اقول حضرتك يعني من خلالك جبهه
كفاح السودانيه لماذا تعتقد حضرتك بانه
هذا النزاع هو النزاع السياسي بالاساس
وليس عسكري
في البدايه التحيه لكم وحقيقه
حل اي مشكله يبدا في التشخيص الصحيح لهذه
المشكله واقطاع الحلول الناجزه لها انا
مفتقد انه الصراع الحقيقي في السودان هو
صراع سياسي
واتى الصراع بين المكونات العسكري
اتت للفترات الاخيره يعني أنا
القرارات 25 اكتوبر الجنرال كانوا على
الاقل رجل واحد في في اظهار هذه القرارات
ولذلك افتكر انه اقتراح حقيقه بدا بعد
التوقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي الاتفاق
الايطالي
الراسين للمكون العسكري وفي اغلب المراحل
دائما يكون القائد العام هو الشخص اللي
يمثل الجيش وبما انه قوات الدعم السريع
جزء من القوات المسلحه لنص القانون بتاع
الدعم السريع انا افتكر انه الاداره
الايطالي لهذا الانقسام الداين وكما شهدتم
في توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي وقع عن القوات
المسلحه للعامه الفريق البرهان وعلى
القوات الد السريع لنرى جديد انا افتكر
بدات الازمه والانقسام بدا من توقيع على
الاكتشاف الايطالي ولكن سيد حذيفه
القوه المدنيه عززت هذا الانقسام وعملت
على مجموعه
على عسكريه
داخل هذه المؤسسه بل هذه القوه السياسيه
المدنيه صرحت
[موسيقى]
الورشه الاصلاح الامني صرحت باكثر من مين
برضو انها سوف تبدا لخيارات اخرى في
[موسيقى]
حاله طرف
العسكري المتحالف معها
في هذه الحرب انا افتكر انه
صحيح ولكن سيد حذيفه اسمح لي ان اقول
كيف صحيح ولكن يقول البعض بان كل هذا
النقاش امتداد لاشهر ولم يكن هناك انزلاق
لصراح لصراع مسلح البعض يقول بان
اليوم المفصلي كان اجتماع سته ابريل ما
الذي يمكن يكون ان حدث في سته ابريل في
هذا الاجتماع
انا افتكر انه
هنالك نقود كبير جدا بين الاطراف المشهد
السياسي وابني كبير جدا بين المكون
العسكري
وهذا ما قادر التوتر اضف الى ذلك انه
الاليه الثلاثيه الامم المتحده والاليه
الرباعيه
هذا الانقسام وحاولت
الانحياز لسيئه قليله من القوه السياسيه
غير ذات السند الشعبي
[موسيقى]
تكونت بعد 11 ابريل فكيف لها ان تتحدث
تقييم وتقويم القوات المسلحه وطبق
الاياديها في هذه المؤسسه الوطنيه
التي تاسست منذ عام 1925 وليس لها
اجابات
صحيح ولكن هو في كل حالات كانت هناك
اجابات واضاحات من الطرفين وسنبقى نحن في
متابعتها اود شكرا جزيل الشكر على هذا
الموقف وهذا التوضيح حذيفه محي الدين
البلول
نائب رئيس جبهه كفاح السودانيه كنت معنا
من جوبا شكرا جزيلا لك
ومشاهدينا في اخر اخبار عمليات الاجلاء
الجاريه من السودان الاردن اعلن عن اربع
طائرات هبطت في السودان استعدادا لاجلاء
رعاياها هناك سنتابع هذا تطور وهذا
الموضوع مع السفير سينا المجالي الناطق
باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه معالي السفير اهلا
بك معنا اربع طائرات الاردن وضعها في خدمه
جليته فداخل السوداني حدثنا عن المزيد من
التفاصيل لو سمحت
نعم سيدتي
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله الطائرات الاردنيه وصلت الى
مطار بورسودان وهي الان على على وشك
الاقلاع باتجاه الاردن ان شاء الله
عمليه الاجلاء او مخطط الاجلاء كانت على
عده مراحل سيدتي اللي قام فيها الاردن و
تكاد تكون من العمليات الكبيره اللي حدثت
في السودان بلغ عدد الاشخاص اللي اللي تم
اجلائهم او سيتم اجلاهم تقريبا يفوق ال
300 شخص
من ضمنهم مواطنين من من دول صديقه
وشقيقه
عملنا جهد في في ضمان امن وسلامه
المواطنين الاردنيين من خلال الخطه التي
وضعت باحكام والتي قد تكون اخذت وقت طويل
ولكن الحمد لله النتائج كانت ايجابيه
ووصلوا للجميع بامن والسلام وان شاء الله
بيرجع الاردن بسلام
استاذ مجال نتحدث عن اربع طائرات وهذه اي
خطط الاجلاء ستتم على مرحله واحده ام هذه
خطه تعتمد مراحل عديده او مرحلتين مثلا
كما فعلت بعض الدول الاخرى كفرنسا
نعم سيدتي احنا العدد العدد اللي تقريبا
دعونا المواطنين الاردنيين لمغادره
السودان
وتجاوبت الرجاله الاردنيه الموجوده في
السودان باعداد
باغلبها تقريبا معنا في في هذه الخطه واود
ان اوجه لهم التحيه
للانضباط والصبر اللي اللي اللي مارسوه
معنا من خلال هذه الخطه التي كانت تخللتها
بعض يعني الصعوبات تعلمين سيدتي الوضع ليس
بالسهل منطقه
بورسودان تبتعد عن عن عن الخرطوم باكثر من
1200 كيلو متر كان هناك صعوبات في في
للوصول الى الى منطقه
استاذ مجالي لو نتحدث اكثر عن هذه
التفاصيل من امن نقلهم من الخرطوم الى
مطار بورتسودان
نعم سيدتي نحن كوزاره خارجيه اردنيه قمنا
بتامين انتقالهم من
بورسودا من الخرطوم الى بورسودان بالكامل
ولكن تم هناك تنسيق مع العديد من الدول
وفي مقدمه ذلك
الاخوه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده وبعض الدول
الصديقه ممن كان العمل من خلال التنسيق
للبحث افضل السبل
والتعاون في تبادر المعلومات حول الممرات
الامنه ومراكز
ونقاط الاتصال هذا الامر كان غايه في
الاهميه سيدتي ساعد في انجاح هذه الخطه
فال العمليه بالظروف الامنيه افهم بانكم
تعاونتم مع الجانبين مع قوه مع الجيش
السوداني وكذلك مع دعم السريع
سيدتي نحن يعني بالاخر فيما يتعلق في
روابط الاخوه التي تربطنا مع الاشقاء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي الامارات
العربيه المتحده ومعظم الدول العربيه
نتعاون بشكل بشكل مطلق في كافه المجالات
بما في ذلك يعني موضوع
التعاون في في تبادل المعلومات والنقاط
الاتصال
ومن خلال
الجهود التي تقدمتها يعني وهذا التنسيق
الذي تم في هذا الموضوع ونشكر
اسمح لي فقط ان افهم من حضرتك بمعنى انه
السلطات الاردنيه لم تتواصل مباشره مع
الدعم السريع
او وانما تواصلتم مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مع الامارات المتحده وهم من
مكنوكم من بعض الاخبار وتفاصيل الممرات
الامنه لوصول رعاياكم وجليتكم الى مطار
بورتسودان صحيح وضح لي صوره لو سمحت
سيدتي نحن تواصلنا مع كل من كان له
القدره على ايصال المواطن الاردني بامان
الى المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه ووصولهم
مقدم بالبدايه الى الى الى بورتسودان
ونشكر كل من ساعدنا في هذا في هذا الموضوع
طيب نتحدث عن جاليه اردنيه كبيره فداخل
السوداني تحدثني عن 300 شخص نفهم بان
ستكون هناك
مراحل اخرى مراحل ثانيه سيد مجالك
سيدتي
بالسودان ليس بذلك العدد الكبير ونحن
عندما تحدثنا عن عن 300 شخص نقول انه
هؤلاء يمثلون
اغلب المواطنين الاردنيين في السودان هناك
عدد متبقي في السودان حسب ما ما نعلم
ولكنه ليس اكبر من العدد الذي تم اجلاؤه
بالمطلق اود شكرك على المشاركه وعلى ساعات
صدرك وسلامه لكل السلامه لكل الاردنيين
الذين خرجوا من السودان باتجاه المملكه
الاردنيه من عمان سفيرسنا المجاليه الناطق
باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه شكرا لك
موقع السودان المتميز في القاره الافريقيه
مشاهدينا جعله وعالقا بشبكه مصالح اقليميه
ودوليه واسعه تلقي بظلالها بشكل مستمر على
مشهده السياسي نفهم اكثر من خلال هذا
التقرير
لا هدنه صمدت ولا حسم يلوح بالافق نوبات
قتال شرعت لها ارض السودان الخصبه
للنزاعات مع غياب استعداد للتسويه شبكه من
المصالح والتقاطعات الاقليميه والدوليه
القت بظلالها على مشهد السودان السياسي
باستمرار في ظل موقعه الافريقي المتميز
ومساعي طي الازمه السياسيه افرز التقسيمات
في تعامل بعض الدول مع الازمه
علاقات الخرطوم المتميزه بالروس ليست
جديده تعد موسكو حليفا دبلوماسيا وعسكريا
لها تمكنت من خلالها توسيع حلقات تعاونها
الامني مع السودان خاصه مع امتلاك الاخير
موقعا مهما على البحر الاحمر المصالح وصلت
الى كنز السودان المدفون الذهب
اتهم الغرب مجموعه فاجن الروسيه بالتورط
في انشطه غير قانونيه لتعدين الذهب في
السودان اما بالنسبه للجناح الغربي
وواشنطن فس بالتخلص من البشير التي تتهمه
المحكمه الدوليه بارتكاب جرائم حرب اثناء
الصراع في دارفور لم تملا تصدعات هذا
البلد الهش كما اتهمت واشنطن بالتلكؤ في
دعم الانتقال نحو اجراء انتخابات اما
بالنسبه للصين يعد السودان حلقه وصل مهمه
بين المحيطين العربي والافريقي لكنها تبنت
نهجا اكثر حذرا تجاه الصراع في السودان
اتسعى الى الحفاظ على التوازن بين مصالح
الاقتصاديه والالتزام بعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول الاخرى
الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع اجذب مشاركه كبيره من اللاعبين
الاقليميين والدوليين ولكل منهم دوافعه
ومصالحه الخاصه
اياد حمود العربيه
متابعه هذه
المواضيع وانعكاس ما يحدث في داخل السودان
على دول الجوار مع ضيفنا من بنغازي
الدكتور فرج زيدان البحث السياسي
والاستراتيجيه الليبي دكتور فرج اهلا بك
معنا ليبيا كذلك هي من الدول المجاوره
للسودان دوله جاره وبالتالي ما يحدث اليوم
هل هناك قراءه او مخاوف خلينا نقول بان
نقادر ان ينسحب على الحدود من الشماليه
الغربيه باتجاه ليبيا
بدايه مساء الخير لحضرتك والساده
المشاهدين وكل عام والجميع بخير
بالتاكيد بان ما يحصل الان من صدام مسلح
في السودان لديه تداعيات خطيره على
المنطقه سواء شمال افريقيا من بينها ليبيا
ايضا منطقه الساحل الافريقي بالاضافه الى
ذلك منطقه البحر الاحمر ولديه تاثير ايضا
في الشمال باتجاه اوروبا لعده اسباب لان
عندما نتكلم عن مساله سيناريو الصدام
المسلح هذه المساله سيكون لديها تداعيات
كارثيه
طبعا الاوضاع الداخليه في السودان زياده
الفقر السودانيين في الداخل
ايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك
زياده مساله الجرائم المنظمه استغلال
لربما التنظيمات الارهابيه هذه المسائل
ومن ثم ستؤدي الى مزيد من تدفقات الهجره
غير الشرعيه هذه نقطه بالاضافه الى ذلك ان
هذه المساله وعدم
السودان
ستؤدي الى عدم القيام الدوله السودانيه
بالتزامها في محيطها الافريقي والعربي
فمثلا عندما بما اننا نتكلم عن تداعيات
الازمه السودانيه على الشمال الغربي وعلى
ليبيا السودان منخرطه في المسار العسكري
الليبي الذي ترعه الامم المتحده عبر لجنه
اتصال باعتبار ان ثمه مرتزقه او فصائل
معارضه سودانيه موجودين في الجنوب الليبي
عوده هؤلاء المعارضه للسودان في اطار
تتطلب ان يكون السودان مستقر وان تحدث
تسويه سياسيه لان لابد ان مصالحه لان هذه
المعارضه اهداف وسياسيه بالاساس
هذا التفصيل هذه المجموعات المسلحه
الموجوده في الجنوب الليبي تتحدث عن مخاوف
ام ان هناك مؤشرات بان هناك شيء يحضر
يعني لا انا اعتقد بان مساله تحضير التي
يعني يتكلم عنها بعض التقارير الاعلاميه
وهو نقطه اخرى في في النقاش
يعني اعتقد بانها مساله غير دقيقه جدا
لماذا نقول هذه المساله بانه لا يوجد هناك
يعني تستطيع ان تقول توافق سياسي مثلا بين
بعض فصائل المعارضه السودانيه مثلا مع
حميدتي على سبيل المثال الى
لازال هناك تنافس يحدث ما بين هذه الفصائل
مع فصيل حميدتي ليسوا على اتفاق كامل في
هذه النقطه ايضا التقارير التي تشير
بطريقه او باخرى علاقه مثلا الجيش ودعم
حميدتي هذه الكلام اعتقد مساله غير دقيقه
بالكامل لان هذه المساله كما قلت لك من
خلال يعني نقاشها الموضوعي او بحثها
الموضوعي ستؤثر بشكل كبير جدا على استقرار
الجنوب الليبي الليبيين يحتاجون الى
استقرار بشكل استراتيجي السودان بح تستطيع
السودان الان ان تحتوي فصائل المعارضه وان
تقوم هناك مصالحه لفصائل المعارضه وان
تنسحب من الجنوب وهذا ما سينجح المسار
العسكري نقطه مهمه اما ان يزيد السودان
قتالا نعم في جنوب ليبيا تعقيدا وهذا
مفهوم ولكن دكتور الجنوب الليبي من على
الحدود او على مستوى الحدود مع السودان من
يسيطر عليه
عمليا الان هذه المنطقه هي تحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه لكن الحدود متراميه
الاطراف السيطره الفعليه العمليه تحتاج
الى ماذا الى ان يمتلك الجيش وسائل
التكنولوجيا الحديثه ان تكون اعداد الجيش
الليبي يعتبر جيش صغير الان
للتمركزاته تمثل مجموعه من نقاط انتشار
خاصه بان الحدود ليست مع السودان ايضا مع
تشاد والحدود مع تشاد والنيجر ومن ثم
المساله لا ترتكز فقط على السودان تظل
رقابه الجيش الليبي وتواجده يعتبر ضعيف
الى حد ما بالاضافه لذلك ان الجيش الليبي
لا يمتلك التكنولوجيا ولا يمتلك التقنيه
هذه نقطه اذا ما اضفنا بالاضافه الى ملف
المرتزقه ملفق الهجره غير الشرعيه وهو
لديه تاثير كبير
في الجنوب الامن الديموغرافي في الجنوبي
الليبي هل تعلمين الان التقارير التي
تتحدث عن مساله الان هجره الليبيون من
الجنوب وان هناك او تغيير ديموغرافي في
هذه النقطه هذه المساله ايضا ستلقي
بظلالها حتى على الجيش وامن الجيش وحدات
الجيش في الجنوب الان ومن ثم المساله
خطيره جدا اذا المصلحه تقترض لماذا ان
يستقر السوداني المساله عدم استقرار
السوداني نعم نعم عن موضوع الهجره المنظمه
او الهجره غير الشرعيه حضرتك تحدثت او قبل
ان نتابع فقط نشير الى هذا العاجل الصحه
العالميه تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى جرى
الاشتباكات بالسودان الى 420 وارتفاع كذلك
عدد الاصابات الى
3700 اذا من خلال هذا العاجل ان نؤكد على
ان الصحه العالميه تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى جرى الاشتباكات في السودان الى 420
وارتفاع عدد الاصابات الى
3700 وهي اعداد مرجحه لان تزداد وتزيد
خاصه وان هناك مناطق
تعذر على المنظمات الوصول لها اعود لك من
جديد دكتور دكتور حدثني عن الهجره المنظمه
وانعكاسها على الامن الليبي ولكن حضرتك
تعلم بان هذا الموضوع جد حساس كذلك فيما
يخص اوروبا وكما يقول الاوروبيون امنهم
مهدد بهذه الهجره الغير شرعيه ونحن نتابع
ملفات الهجره المنطلقه من القرن الافريقي
باتجاه السودان صعودا الى ليبيا ومتجهين
فيما بعد الى اوروبا هل تعتقد بان هذه
الازمه ستؤثر على هذا الملف
بالتاكيد بان تدفقات الهجره غير الشرعيه
ستزداد لان السودان عندما
يعني يفشل في مساله الضبط يعني
وضعه الامني واستقراره وسيطرته الامنيه
على على الدوله في الداخل الامر فهذا
الامر سيزيد الهجره ليس من قبل السودان
فقط هناك دول اخرى افريقيه دول تعتبر
تستطيع ان تصفينها بانها دول فاشله ستستغل
هذه النقطه الان خاصه بان السودان الان
لديه اتصال مع دول غير مستقره عندما نتحدث
عن اثيوبيا نتحدث عن افريقيا الوسطى نتحدث
عن ارتريا منطقه القرن الافريقي بالكامل
ومن ثم هذه المساله الان ستزيد من زياده
تدفقات الهجره غير الشرعيه الان التقارير
حتى تعرض مثلا حتى على قناتي العربيه
والعربيه الحدث عن نزوح كبير جدا من يعني
من المواطنين السودانيين سواء باتجاه
النزوح داخلي او حتى نزوح خارجي ومن ثم
سائق خاصه الان بان لربما سيكون مرشحا بعد
ان تقوم الجاليات الاجنبيه باجلاء كامل
المواطنيها والدبلوماسيه ومن ثم القتال
مرشح للازدياد الان ومن ثم كلما ازدادت
رقعه هذا القتال كلما ازداد عدد المهاجرين
من اكثر من ولايه ومن ثم سيكون مثلا على
سبيل المثال التوجه باتجاه الممر الليبي
وهو يعني يعتبر من اكثر الممرات نظرا لان
هذا الممر الان ضعيف الرقابه بشانه
والمهاجرين يدركون هذه النقطه بالاضافه
الى ذلك بان هناك جاليه سودانيه كبيره في
ليبيا ويرغب عدد كبير من المواطنين في
السودان من الالتحاق يعني باقرباء من
الجاليه السودانيه في ليبيا الان خاصه مع
تثبيت مبدا وقف اطلاق النار في ليبيا
المساله في تقدير يعني مساله صعبه جدا
تاثيرها عندما نتحدث عن الملف بشكل خاص ان
يكون تاثير كبير بالاضافه الى دول الساحل
ومصر يعني فقط دكتور لو سمحت
هذا الملف صحيح بانه معقد ولكن البعض يقول
بانه طالما الصراع لازال مقتصر او محدود
في مناطق معينه نتحدث عن الخرطوم على
كردفان وكذلك على اندرمان في بعض المناطق
في هاتين المنطقتين الاخيرتين كيف يمكن
العمل وحضرتك باحث سياسي واستراتيجي
والاكيد بان لك خبره كذلك في قراءه هذه
التطورات ما الذي يجب فعله حتى لا تتوسع
رقعه هذه الاشتباكات اكثر
يعني انا في تقديري اولا يجب كبح يعني ان
تتوقف الدول يعني المتدخله في الصراع عن
تفعيل هذا الصراع هذه نقطه مهمه جدا هذا
نقطه هذه للاطراف الخارجيه وانا اعتقد
يعني التقارير تعج عن مساله التدخل
والاطراف المتدخله في هذا الشان الان وانا
في تقدير النقطه التي يجب نصيحه اقولها
للسيد يعني عبد الفتاح البرهان نقطه مهمه
جدا لان امن السودان السودان يعني بلد
جوار ونحن نهتم بامن هذه البلد مساله
المصالحه على اطراف الاسلام السياسي
والانفتاح عليهم لاسيما عندما نتحدث عن
بعض يعني العناصر من عندما نتحدث من
الجماعه الاسلاميه او حتى من المؤتمر
الوطني انا اعتقد بانه كان يعني نقطه
كبيره جدا يعني فجرت الاوضاع في ليبيا ومن
ثم يجب على قوى الثوره في الداخل السوداني
انا في تقديري ان تتجمع الان ويجب على
حميدتي والب رهان ان يعلو المصلحه الوطنيه
في الداخل لان مساله يعني هذه نصيحه
اعلائهم للمصالح الخاصه وبالاضافه الى ذلك
التدخل
هذه نصيحه فقط الساده يعني ومن ثم هناك
هذه نصيحه فقط اجابه على سؤال حضرتكم
لمساله وقت اطلق دكتور فرج زيدان البحث
السياسي الليبي كنت معنا من بنغازي شكرًا
جزيلا
الى موضوع اخر او مجموعه من المواضيع
الاخرى المتعلقه بالتطورات في السودان حيث
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك قال
ان القوات المسلحه اتمت عمليه اجراء معقده
وسريعه للدبلوماسيين البريطانيين
ولعائلتهم من السودان مضيفا ان بريطانيا
تسعى بكل الوسائل لوقف اراقه الدماء في
السودان وضمان سلامه البريطانيين المتبقين
هناك وانها تحث الاطراف كافه على القاء
الاسلحه وايقاف اطلاق النار
وكان قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بينوالاس
على صفحته على تويتر ان القوات المسلحه
البريطانيه نفذت عمليه الى جانب الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا وحلفاء اخرين واجلت موظفي
السفاره البريطانيه وعائلتهم من الخرطوم
بسبب التهديدات المتصاعده مشيرا الى
مشاركه 1200 جندي بريطاني في العمليه منهم
سته عشر لواء هجوم جوي ومشاه البحريه
الملكيه وسلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني
اكثر تفاصيل ربما وقراءه لهذه التطورات مع
زميله من لندن مستفزه العربيه مصطفى اهلا
بك معنا مصطفى هل تحدثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل
عمليه الاجلاء هذه التي قامت بها بريطانيا
ما تم الاشاره اليه من خلال
التغريدات لرئيس الوزراء او
لوزير الدفاع او حتى تصريح لوزير الخارجيه
نعرف بان
عناصر تقريبا 1200 من افراد الجيش
البريطاني شاركوا في هذه العمليه لاجلاء
دبلوماسيه من العاصمه الخرطوم كانت هناك
طائرتان عسكريتان
يعني من خلالهما تم اجلاء
الدبلوماسيه البريطانيين من السفاره
البريطانيه في الخرطوم وهذه واتاني
الطائرتين
انتقل انتقل من القاعده العسكريه
البريطانيه
في قبرص واتجهت الى السودان في في مطار
هناك ربما يبعد بحوالي 30 كيلومتر عن مقر
السفاره كانت على الارجح ان هناك ايضا
ربما فريقا من القوات الخاصه التي قامت
بها هذه العمليه بسبب التصعيد الكبير في
اعمال العنف وتهديدات موظفي السفاره
وبعثات الدبلوماسيه اخرى فكانت هناك فرصه
سانحه بحسب المسؤولين البريطانيين لاجلاء
الموظفين وافراد عائلتهم الى الى الى
اكريتوري في قبرص وعلى الارجح يتم نقل
هؤلاء الموظفين الدبلوماسيين الى السفارات
اخرى مجاوره في السودان للقيام باعمالهم
ربما البعض يتساءل عن عدد الذين هم
الخارجيه لم تكشف عن العدد لكن نتوقع ان
تكون هناك العشرات
كان هناك بان لدى بريطانيا ربما خمسه
وعشرين موظفا دبلوماسيا في السفاره
بالاضافه الى افراد عائلته
فقط فقط لنحاول ان نفهم هذا الموضوع لان
بان والاس وزير الدفاع البريطاني يتحدث عن
مشاركه 1100 جندي بريطاني في العمليه
ومن بينهم سته عشر لواء نتحدث عن عشرات
مصطفى او ربما قد يكون العدد اكبر
يعني في البدايه كانت هناك طائرتان لا
نعلم السعه هاتين الطائرتين لكن اذا ما
نتحدث عن الطائره العسكريه 130 هي يعني
تتسع للعشرات
للمسافرين وبالتالي يعني كانت وزاره
الخارجيه حريصه وحتى وزير الدفاع حريص على
ان لا يكشف عن العدد الحقيقي ما يقلق
المسؤولين حاليا حقيقه وهو
البريطانيون العالقون حاليا المد
نيون كانت هناك مناشده من بعضهم يقولون
بان الحكومه تخلت عنهم ولكن الظروف غير
مناسبه لهؤلاء بحسب بحسب المسؤولين
البريطانيه ويتم التنسيق ايضا مع الحلفاء
لاجلاء العالقين من الجنسيات المختلفه
خاصه الاوروبيه والامريكيه من لان هناك
تنسيق بين هذه الدول بالطبع
الحكومه يعني مصره ان ان تقوم بما بما
يلزم لحمايه مواطنها لكن في الوقت الحاضر
ليست هناك فرصه صانحه لاجلاء هؤلاء
وبالتالي تم مناشدتهم ومسحهم بالتسجيل
بالتسجيل اسمائهم مع مع يعني وزاره
الخارجيه بانتظار تعليمات اخرى لاحقا لكن
يعني هذه العمليه هي كانت عمليه كما ذكر
كما اشر رئيس الوزراء كانت معقده وسريعه
واشد في نفس الوقت بشجاعه القوات التي
نفذت هذه العمليه العسكريه الصعبه الى
جانب الولايات المتحده وفرنسا وحلفاء
اخرين مصطفى تلقوا المساعده من من في داخل
السوداني هل تناولت بعض التصريحات
السياسيه هكذا تفاصيل
حقيقه ليست هناك تفاصيل يعني
متوفره حتى هذه اللحظه ولربما هناك تكتم
بسبب الاجراءات يعني الجاريه هناك حتى هذه
اللحظه لكن نعرف بان على الاقل الموظفين
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين هم خارج السودان
حاليا بينما تتعالى اصوات الانتقادات من
داخل يعني
داخل السودان قبل المواطنات البريطانيين
ولكن بالاشاره الى من ساعدوا بريطانيا
وايضا كان هناك تنسيق بين الولايات
المتحده وفرنس بالاضافه الى ايضا كان هناك
تنسيق مع
الاطراف
المتنحره في في السودان وخاصه
بين الجيش يعني السوداني وايضا قوات الدعم
العسكريه
هذه العمليه يعني كانت تقريبا في في
الواحده صباحا وتم نقل هؤلاء وكان يجب على
الفريق الذي كان فريق القوات الخاصه الذي
كان يرافق الموظفين الدبلوماسيين
البريطانيين من السفاره الى المطار يعني
كان يجب ان يتجاوزوا بعض النقاط التفتيش
للصراع وتواجد مكان حقيقه مكان السفاره
البريطانيه هو يعني في وسط المدينه وكانت
هناك يعني
الاطلاق الرصاص من من من مختلف الجهات
وبالتالي
قال بانها عمليه سريعه ومعقده خاصه سنبقى
في انتظار المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه
التصريحات وكيف تمت هذه العمليه اود شكرك
جزيل الشكر من لندن مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه شكرا لك
مشاهدينا اتهامات متبادله بين قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان المعروف بحميدتي
فخلال لقائهما غير المباشر عبر العربيه
اتهم كل طرفنا الاخر الحرب وخرق الهدنه
والهجوم على منازل السكان وكذلك البعثات
الاجنبيه نتابع
البرهان وحماتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحماتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
اليوم
علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
[موسيقى]
مجموعات كثيره جدا من هذه القوات وسط
الاحياء السكنيه
المهندسين والراجمال
اين يوجد البرهان وحماتي انا موجود
المسلحه ومبارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي
وهذا شرفي من اخرج الا محمولا على نعش
الخرطوم
الشوارع موجود مع مواليد انا موجود في كل
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في
الهودنه حتى ابتدعت لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الاحياء
السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام اليوم احنا كنا
موجودين في الغراتنا وتم الهجوم علينا من
قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
الى اي مدى هذه الحرب انا اقول ان هذه
الحرب ليس فيها كاسيت
افدت مصادر العربيه باعطاء مصر ضوء الاخضر
لبدء عمليه الاجراء من السودان حيث قالت
المصادر ان الجيش المصري نسق مع نظيره
السوداني لبدء العمليات كما اشارت مصادر
العربيه الى ان الجيش السوداني سيتولم
مرافقه قوافل المصريين حتى المعابر
الحدوديه وان السودان زود مصر بتفاصيل
الممرات الامنه لنقل المصريين لاماكن
الاجلاء وكانت مصر نشرت قوه امنيه على
معابرها الحدوديه مع السودان لتامين عمليه
الاجلاء
بدات في السودان اولى عمليه اجراء الجاليه
الموريتانيه من الخرطوم وذلك بمساعده من
السعوديه وتم نقل نساء واطفال من الجاليه
الموريتانيه من ميناء بورتسودان الى ميناء
جده لترتيب عودتهم لبلادهم
مشاهدينا ننتقل لهذا المقطع المتداول
لهجوم على سجن كوبر بالخرطوم وانباء عن
هروب سجناء نتابع هذا المقطع ومن ثم نعود
لنستكمل بقيه هذه الاخبار المتعلقه سواء
بالتطورات في السودان وكذلك موجز لاخر
الاخبار الدوليه
نكمل مع اخبار السودان وعلى صعيد الجهود
الدوليه والاقليميه بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل بحث الجهود المبذوله لوقف
التصعيد العسكري بين الاطراف المتنازعه
وانهاء العنف السودان اضافه الى توفير
الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين السودانيين
والمقيمين مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف عن توافق صعودي
اوروبي على العمل الجماعي من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان
كذلك مشاهدينا في اخبار اخرى
نتابعها اخبار متنوعه ونافذه ونفتحها على
ما يحدث ولكن قبل ذلك في الكويت عدا اليوم
25 مواطنا قادمين من مطار جدولي في
السعوديه وذلك في اطار الخطه الطارئه التي
نفذتها وزاره الخارجيه الكويتيه لاجلاء
المواطنين العالقين جراء الاشتباكات
المسلحه والتطورات الامنيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
كذلك وزير الخارجيه السعودي بحث هاتفيا مع
رئيس الوزراء القطري ووزير الخارجيه محمد
بن عبد الرحمن بن جاسم الثاني جهودا وقف
التصعيد العسكري في السودان وناقش
الوزيران ايضا جهود توفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين السودانيين وتهدئه التوترات
المتصاعده في العديد من المواقع الحيويه
داخل السودان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات